the way we've talked about the rise of
the social contra
following the Second World War might
make it seem a little bit more utopian
than was actually the case wages did
rise in tandem with productivity and
this meant a high standard of living for
many Americans there was also less
emphasis on shareholders and immediate
short-term returns there was also high
levels of job stability people often
came into a company without very much
experience at all and expected to work
their way up through promotions overtime
but there were also downsides to
employment over this period the
trade-off of job security of having a
stable career with a predictable career
trajectory was often the risk of boredom
and monotonous work corporations in the
1950s were very hierarchical and
conformist intellectual diversity and
creativity were discouraged these
corporations of course were also
dominated by white men there wasn't very
much diversity and there were very
sizeable gaps in pay based on gender and
race so while we can learn a lot from
this period it's not exactly a golden
age to which we should return we've made
a lot of progress since this period as
well there's more diversity in the
workforce than ever before and pay gaps
between demographic groups though they
still exist are becoming smaller with
the rise of the knowledge economy
moreover an economy that encourages
ideas and creativity and innovation
workers are being given more discretion
in how they go about their work and even
the types of projects on which they work
some organizations are even trying to
make themselves look and feel as
non-corporate e as possible as a way to
attract and retain talent and there's
evidence that this can be good for the
bottom line in addition due in large
part to advances in information
technology new technology mediated work
arrangements are becoming more popular
and facilitating various forms of
freelance work freelancing is not new of
course the word actually dates back to
medieval times where one could be a
freelance mercenary for hire various new
websites and applications are springing
up throughout the economy that connect
people buyers and sellers in unique and
innovative ways
so for software for example there's
companies like freelancer comm where
someone can go on and post a project for
example solicit help coding a new
website and people will bid on those
projects I actually use one of these
sites not for a website per se but to
help me learn a new coding language
called Python I went on the site I
posted my project and I found an
undergraduate student based in
California a very bright young man who
stayed up with me into the early hours
of the morning helping me learn how to
code and there are plenty of other
examples of technology mediated work
Mechanical Turk for example where buyers
can pay people to do basic often routine
tasks like taking surveys TaskRabbit
comm where people can find people to do
basic life chores for them in care.com
where people can locate for example
house and pet sitters for when they are
away these alternative modes of
employment have distinct advantages in
terms of flexibility and individual
expression people don't typically have a
boss looking over their shoulder at
least not in a physical sense they have
flexibility to work different hours
often from various locations including
their own home but there are common
reoccurring disadvantages to these modes
of work as well there are high levels of
uncertainty and insecurity you don't
know whether you'll have one work from
one month to the next you don't know who
your next boss will be whether they'll
be fair and ethical whether they'll pay
in a timely way if you have an issue
with an employer for example withholding
promised pay it's often difficult to
resolve these issues there's broad often
global competition which can put
downward pressure on wages so for
example when I hired this this coder to
help me with this freelancing project he
was competing against people located in
China and India there are other trade
offs as well there's isolation a lack of
pension and retirement lack of paid
vacation and time off the need for
continuous learning that can accommodate
the diverse and changing needs of
employers and needing to finance that
education out of your own pocket in
addition many of these employees lack
the protections that are traditionally
afforded to workers under more stable
and
employment contracts
you